en 1991
je m'en vais donc pour mon premier
voyage au sénégal
et là je m'en vais dans un village qui
s'appelle tandis mal je rencontre quinze
femmes 15 femmes exceptionnelles elles
sont jeunes dynamiques plein de vie et
comme tout le monde elle rêve de
réaliser dans leur île à tout ce qui
peut avoir de plus beau de plus
magnifique c'est à dire à ce que les
hommes et les femmes dans 2 tandis mâles
vivent comme ces êtres humains dit de
vivre dans une vie libre et une vie où
c'est qu'ils ont accès à leurs soins à
l'école et à l'eau potable
alors qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire ces
quinze femmes dans les médias et merlot
elles vont à dakar espérant trouver
l'eldorado
hélas les rêves ne se réalisent pas
toujours de la façon qu'on veut elle
pour violences prostitution viol elle
finalement elle secrète ingénieux et
danseuses et lieu elle vous allez
travailler le matin dans les maisons
dans l'après midi elle montalet l'école
jusque tard le soir et elle vous dormir
dans les quelques cartons autour de la
périphérie de dakar deux oreilles
ces femmes confondus elles savent elles
ont les premiers gestes qui sauvent
elles savent cultiver un jardin planté
tout ce qu'on peut planter comme arbres
fruitiers
elles savent coudre elles savent perle
lama tic qui font merveille
elles savent élever les boules comme
nous tous est-ce que c'est très
difficile car j'ai appris depuis tout
petit ou le 3 ans les voilà regagnant
leur village
et elles ont pu créer ce qu'elle voulait
avec leur force et le courage leurs
produits la récolte de leurs produits a
demandé dès la récolte a été très
bénéfique et ces femmes
aujourd'hui elles peuvent elles peuvent
dire qu'elles ont réalisé leur rêve voir
les villageois habitant human vivre ses
ancêtres ses grands parents leurs grands
pères leurs enfants vivre comme tous les
autres êtres humains après plus près de
nous à madagascar
une jeune fille cartes pré saison
débarque à la maison et les malgaches
elle était acceptée à sept maris pour
faire un bac pro ce qu'elle avait
soulevé une comptabilité embauches
je ne la connais pas elle est envoyée
par un orphelinat cela cette volonté
chez moi je vais à l'avion la règle a
récupéré je trouve une jeune fille
souriante juvénile plein de vie et qui
n'a qu'une seule envie réussir
voilà notre claire qui commence ses
études et qui arrive qui passe son bac
pro qui réussit merveilleusement bien et
elle passe son bts cet enfant aurait pu
aller beaucoup beaucoup plus loin elle
avait les dispositions pour elle pouvait
devenir commissaire aux comptes
expert comptable mais vous savez tous
comme moi que madagascar est un des pays
les plus pauvres au monde
alors qu'est ce qu'elle fait plus rien
ne la retient elle va à madagascar elle
retourne dans son pays
et la voilà à la tête d'un centre de vie
les terreaux de l'espoir ce centre de
vie à 40 enfants un arc 22 ans
son souci principal est de se dire
il faut que je les reconstruisent ces
gamins que j'ai retiré de la rue qui
sont tous soient orphelins soit victime
soit enfants victimes de violence soit
enfants de familles très pauvres
il faut que je réussisse à faire d'eux
des hommes et des femmes
inséré dans leur société demain est
heureux de vivre
alors voilà l'exemple de claire qui pour
moi est là aujourd'hui
quand deux ans fait un travail
magnifique et ça elle dort elle pense
aux terreaux de l'espoir elle se lève le
matin c'est son centre de vie elle se
lève le matin elle pense aux terreaux de
l'espoir elles mangent elles vont se
dérouler ce boire ses enfants elle en a
quatre passes longtemps après les autres
enfants d'hétéros de l'espoir et puis
mais cela ne serait pas complète si je
ne vous parlait que de femmes parce que
je suis mère de famille j'ai un garçon
qui c'est à moi de plumeau de tout ce
qui existe au monde
non ça ne vous en faites pas alors donc
je mauvais au sénégal 92 toujours là je
rencontre un homme vraiment exceptionnel
landing sané
il énerve andi mann d'une intelligence
j'ai souvent comme on l'appelle
quand quelqu'un est très intelligente la
caisse des profs comme on l'appelle et
il est très intelligent comme on
l'appelle je ne sais pas enfin toujours
est il qu'il est très intelligent et
comme il a vite d'un animal et de
familles très modestes
tout le village cotisent pour pouvoir
l'envoyer faire ses études
imparable ce jeune homme part à paris et
là il fait en même temps polytechnique
et écoles d'architecturé au bout de
trois ans il est admis il a ses diplômes
et il est brillamment reçus comme on
peut le dire
que c'est monsieur pompidou notre
président de la république
il demande à l'opal sédar senghor son
homologue de venir remettre le diplôme à
ce jeune homme combien d'entreprises
françaises parisienne aurait aimé avoir
ce jeune étudiant parmi leurs employés
lui il n'a pas besoin de réfléchir
tandis man ce village ces hommes ces
femmes ou d'économiser 1 français face à
un franc cfa pour l'envoyer à l'école
dont il ne peut pas rester à paris pour
avoir cette vie cette belle vie qu'on
aurait pu avoir à paris dont il revient
au sénégal
il revient vivre dans son village et de
temps du mal et depuis l'âge de 23 ans
il apporte régulièrement son aile aux
familles les plus démunies
alors vous voyez j'ai envie de vous dire
gens comme ils histoire à vous raconter
je pourrais vous raconter ce fabuleux dr
andré nhtsa qui est médecin à madagascar
et s'occupe uniquement des lépreux qui
pour lui c'est très important de 10 de
tôle et à toutes les poteaux de famille
l'épreuve une dignité de vie mais le
temps va me manquer certainement
alors j'ai envie de vous dire que si
jamais nous soyons au cames seul cas en
amérique en or tout dans n'importe
quelle terre reculer lorsque nous
croisons quelqu'un sur la route cette
personne méthode que nous même et j'ai
envie de dire si vous trouvez quelqu'un
que vous voyez mon et les clochards
hélas pas j'ai pas envie d'aller le
côtoyer allez-y toquer à sa porte
toqué
son temps parce que ce clochard cette
tâche à ce pauvre là il aura toujours
quelque chose à vous apprendre que vous
vous n'aurez pas su pendant toute votre
notre mais l'éducation
j'ai envie aussi de vous dire que chaque
fois que le croisant quelqu'un
n'oublions pas que cette personne est
nous mêmes et il faut peut-être semble
l'a souvent répété savoir aimer mais
émis jusqu'à l'extrême
s'ils s'étaient donné sa vie pour
l'autre et j'ai envie de vous dire que
lorsque nous nous trouvons dans une
situation difficile
pensons à ces gens là ce sont eux qui
vont nous redonner courage pour
redémarrer notre vie d'aujourd'hui
alors nous allons faire quelques
kilomètres en sont peut-être d'être vous
en diront un peu vieillot la drogue mais
c'est pas bien grave large a donné
l'expérience et j'ai envie de vous dire
sous passion crépon créons dans notre
vie beaucoup beaucoup de maisons pour
que ces personnes qui sont démunis qui
se retrouvent à la rue puisse trouver
des maisons dans laquelle nous sommes
dans lesquels ils se retrouveront très
bien créer autour de nous des milliards
et des milliards de maison du bonheur
c'est maison du bonheur
nous allons commencer cette année en
créer une
et nous allons certainement au cours du
temps créneau pour chaque personne qui
entre dans cette maison puisse
comprendre que nous sommes sains et
qu'il n'est pas différent et que nous ne
sommes pas différents de lui même si
nous avons des millions à nos pieds et
lui l'en n'a rien
nous sommes tous un nous sommes tous de
la même façon et nous devons continuer à
nous aimer
ce quelque chose qui est très important
là là on ne ment pas l'art et serviable
la bourriche aridha là peut être dans
toutes les maisons et dans two lovers